so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the anti-life equation
from DC Comics and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of all this you'll have
an understanding of what the equation is
and how it ties into the overall events
of DC rebirth and Darkseid war so the
first mention of the anti-life equation
in DC Comics came with Jack Kirby's
fourth world epic and the forever people
to sidetrack for a second while Jack
Kirby was best known for his work in
creating the x-men Thor spider-man and
the rest of Marvel's original lineup in
the 1960s because his contributions were
continually marginalized leading into
the early 1970s in 1971 he left mobile
comics to pursue work in DC during this
time with most of DC's landscape
consisting of earthbound events and with
his only real exploration coming in the
form of Superman and Green Lantern Jack
Kirby looked to expand the universe of
DC by launching the fourth world as a
self-contained continuity similar to
Marvel's ultimate universe from the
2000s and filled with characters of
Kirby's own creation and design while
these characters did crossover in
stories like Superman's pal Jimmy Olsen
and with Superman directly the idea
behind this was to have them exposed to
DC's larger audience as a jumping-off
platform and an effort to better ensure
a solid start from the series centering
largely on the worlds of New Genesis and
apocalypse as representations of good
and evil respectively the forever people
were established as inhabitants of New
Genesis working to overthrow Darkseid
and his attempts to rule the universe
taking place in issue number 5 during a
conflict between the forever people and
desaad an agent of Darkseid the
anti-life equation was established as
being akin to an energy source which
someone could tap into allowing them to
dominate the Wills of any and all
sentient races as a result the anti-life
equation was given its name owing to the
idea that a person without the ability
to think and function for themselves
wasn't really alive to this end with the
forever people being monitored by both
the sod and dark side during the
skirmish this particular comic
represents the first comic book
appearance by which dark sides interest
in the anti-life equation emerged
however in 2001 s Martian Manhunter
volume 2 issue number 33 as part of DC's
efforts to flesh out John Jones
character outside of the Justice League
the three-part series in my life by John
Ostrander
held the history of John's race in
relation to the anti-life equation
establishing that at some point in the
past the apocalyptan general canto
visited Mars on behalf of Darkseid
speaking with john jones directly and
learning of the Martians life philosophy
it was revealed that the Martians
believed all life was sacred and in
conjunction with their understanding of
Science and Mathematics formed the life
equation as a mathematical proof of
freewill coming to the conclusion that
all things in existence have an
antithesis Darkseid came to the belief
that the life equation must have an
opposite of its own in the form of the
anti-life equation and exist as the
opposite of freewill
now while the origin of the life
equation would receive a red con and the
pages of Geoff Johns Green Lantern
Godhead this revelation in martian
manhunter volume 2 issue number 33
served to provide the idea that from
that point going forward Darkseid had
consistently searched for the anti-life
equation eventually leading into forever
people issue number 5 and his first
witness of its power following this Jack
Kirby's continuation of the forever
pupils story led into issue number 8 and
the introduction of a man named
billion-dollar Bates possessing extreme
wealth due to his natural ability to
access and use the anti-life equation
while this natural ability was never
fully explained Bates had formed a cult
around himself with the intention of
using his power and wealth for world
domination as a result with a forever
people did battle against Bates his
ability to harness the anti-life
equation made him a direct target for
Darkseid leading to the arrival of
Darkseid himself in pursuit of Bates and
his attempts to kill the forever people
and secure the equation Bates was used
as a human shield against Darkseid's
Omega beams killing Bates in the process
and leading Darkseid without the ability
to use the equation now because Jack
Kirby's time in DC was met with strict
editorial control and the inability to
freely expand the Fourth World concept
in accordance with his own vision where
he had vacated his position and returned
to Marvel the fourth world itself was
rolled over into the main DC continuity
with various writers tasked in expanding
on the concept themselves coming in 2001
with Walt Simonson's 25 issue series
Orion which focus on the escapades of
dark sides biological son while the
first five issues were simply reprints
of existing stories from the gates of
apocalypse in addition to the backup
features titled tales of the new guy
and expanding on their own world Walt
Simonson established the following basis
death darkslide had made a series of
clones looking to absorb the entirety of
the anti-life equation from them and
seize control of reality coming into
conflict with Orion who came to view the
anti-life equation as a means to bend
the will of all sentient life in favor
of peace where his goal was achieved and
earth became a utopia of sorts the
efforts of Orion were abandoned owing to
the idea that piece had to be achieved
naturally as opposed to external means
as a result the anti-life equation fell
back into obscurity making a series of
small appearances and DC Comics leading
up to the launch of DC's Final Crisis a
centering on the idea of making the
heroes aware of the multiverses
existence following its destruction
during 1985's crisis on Infinite Earths
and its return during 2005 infinite
crisis because the equation existed as a
mathematical proof right a rant Morrison
used the technological age as a means to
realize Darkseid's goal of dominating
the earth and that with computers
functioning based on mathematical
equations in binary code the anti-life
equation was distributed over the
Internet as a meta-commentary
of society's reliance on technology and
its intertwining in everyday life where
the final crisis event itself was a
massive intermingling of different plot
threads which had been left dangling
following the conclusion of crisis on
Infinite Earths leading up to the modern
day with regards to the anti-life
equation its distribution across the
internet allowed dockside to seize
control of earth by turning various
heroes and villains into his own agents
transforming earth into a new base of
operations and is ongoing war against
New Genesis and to this end where the
final crisis event saw the destruction
of Darkseid at the hands of Superman
using a wishing machine Grant Morrison's
depiction of the equation maintained its
historical function as a mathematical
proof showing the futility of life
meaning that those who were exposed to
it experienced a kind of Awakening and
completely succumbed to the belief that
life is pointless
stripping them of their will to live and
turning them into slaves to the will of
whoever holds the equation having said
that because the origin of the anti-life
equation had never been explored whether
due to a lack of desire or
editorial control when DC launched the
new 52 is a line wide reboot of their
various titles the anti-life equation
received the same treatment during this
time the early line of new 52 related
titles may
in much of the equations function prior
to the start of the new 52 but because
fan reception to the reboot and
subsequent events like convergence and
ECU led to the idea of DC rebirth chief
creative officer Geoff Johns retooled
the anti-life equation in its entirety
tying it directly to the origin of
anti-monitor
and the antimatter universe where the
previous school of thought held that the
anti-monitor was simply a plot device
created for crisis on Infinite Earths
and never really be used again geoff
johns established that much like the
actions of green lantern character Crona
and peering into the origin of the
normal DC universe spawning the life
equation and giving birth to all things
in existence the anti-monitor existed as
a man named mobius and peered into the
origin of the antimatter universe
spawning the anti-life equation becoming
imbued with its power with the new 52
operating as a reboot all previous
information and events within the pages
of comics that pertained to the
anti-life equation were discarded
meaning that chronologically mobius had
discovered the anti-life equation bonded
with it and dark side had simply spent
his entire life looking to access it
leading into the events of Dark Side war
by way of dark sides daughter Grail
looking to kill her father with the help
of Mobius
while act 1 saw the heroes coming
together and Act two saw dark sides
Death Act three and four focused on the
fallout Mobius is transformation and
Grail Neph in this bit here I'd like you
to pay particular attention since this
will be relevant for our discussions on
DC rebirth but with Mobius undergoing a
transformation and ridding himself of
the anti-life equation it had passed a
Grail whose motives be on dark sides
death remained ambiguous but bonded the
equation to Steve Trevor a human allied
to the Amazons an occasional love
interest to Wonder Woman using Steve to
battle Mobius himself and Wonder Woman
directly this conflict was short-lived
and that with earth 3s Lois Lane
becoming pregnant and giving birth to a
child while functioning as a villain
using the moniker superwoman and imbued
with all the powers of Superman Grail
rightly made the assumption that the
baby would possess vast powers akin to
Superman stripping Steve Trevor of the
anti-life equation and bonding into
super woman's baby Grail transform the
child into a reborn Darkseid and used it
to wage war against Earth's heroes
leading to a massive battle that nearly
laid waste to the planet at its
conclusion
Wonder Woman had used her lasso of truth
to calm the mind of grail removing her
rage and allowing her to disperse the
anti-life equation now with regards to
the future of DC we berth and the
equation itself because rebirth is
designed to bring together the best of
the new 52 and prix new 52 continuities
it's unknown if the equation will return
and in what capacity but because of its
ties to the launch of DC rebirth and its
role in previous events it would stand
to reason that even if only as a plot
device the anti-life equation will
likely make a return within the larger
DC continuity with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
let me know whether or not this
explanation on the anti-life equation
made sense to you i'm really curious to
see what you guys have to say and i will
catch you guys under peace